in this lecture we're going to look at
Martin Heidegger's short essay what is
metaphysics it's probably one of the
better introductions I think to some of
the key themes of Heidegger's were
particularly its early work but also
those in his work as a whole and this
was a lecture that he gives early on in
his career but you can see some of the
main themes already emerging and already
you know integrated very well in this
and so he's asking this fundamental
question what is metaphysics and you
notice I put a bunch of other questions
here as well that he's going to travel
through that I put several quotations
here so before we actually go into the
lecture let's let's talk about these to
ask the question what is metaphysics is
to ask the question what is being and
water beings and metaphysics is is a
type of inquiry that traditionally in
philosophy goes beyond other types of
inquiry
you know in Aristotle's case beyond the
physics beyond the phenomenal apparent
world to ask about the reality of things
Heidegger says that in order to think
about this and there's many other people
who thought thought this as well you
also have to ask what is human being and
one branch of metaphysics is what we
call philosophical anthropology or the
philosophy human nature Heidegger is
going to conceive of it in terms of
design or being there a particular type
of being among beings that turns out to
be human beings that has certain
peculiar properties in its very essence
then we've got this this other strange
thing what is the nothing or what is
nothing and for Heidegger to do
metaphysics is not just to ask you know
what are beings and such and then what
is this particular kind of being that
you know grasped so they're beings it's
also to ask about what is nothing what
is the
being what is beyond or underneath or in
some ways you know the negation you know
and we'll talk about why negation by
itself doesn't actually work and here's
a question that he actually starts with
and this is pretty typical Heidegger he
some traipse all over the place in
discussing these things and in a very
you know illuminating ways but he's
going to start with a question that
he'll answer you know a long way fairly
easily revealing greater and deeper
questions so what is it what is science
and then he's going to reframe it as
what is the ground where does the
essence or what is allowing science to
be science so he's beginning with this
question okay what is what is science
you know metaphysics is a type of
science if we understand science not in
terms just of the Natural Sciences or
the social sciences the way that we
often do in the english-speaking world
but in the sense of a rigorous study of
some sort a visit shaft a rigorous study
that is conducted according to its own
norms that attempts to be systematic
that attempts to get to the bottom of
things that's that's what science is so
now you notice I also put these these
quotes here and I've got three of them
and you might say well here's the
beginning here's the middle here's
here's the end so he starts off with
things that seem you know easy enough to
get our heads around every metaphysical
problem always encompasses the whole
range of metaphysical problems right so
any time that we're going to do
metaphysics that we're going to touch on
metaphysical topics like what is reality
versus appearance or what is the nature
of freedom or is the will in fact free
or determinism rule or what kinds of
beings are there we're not just trying
to settle that particular question
according
Heidegger and according to many other
philosophers as well Hegel Nietzsche
going all the way back to people like
Aristotle these these are not dealt with
in complete isolation from each other
well that's something that's not too
hard to to grasp the nothing itself
awaits
now we're in the the realm you know
right in the heart of what is
metaphysics and you might say well what
does that mean and actually this is one
of the phrases that was used by
Heidegger's critics in order to suggest
that that maybe you know Heidegger's
philosophy itself was just a bunch of
nonsense as a matter of fact the logical
positivist said this is sort of the
prime example of nonsense well it's
going to have a meeting in height area
but we have to dig and we have to work
our way through to actually get to that
meeting and then finally at the very end
not not the very last sentence but close
to the end human existence can relate to
beings only if it holds itself out into
the nothing this is this going beyond as
metaphysics itself so it tells us what
metaphysics actually is and that we're
actually doing metaphysics whether we
realize it or not but it's framing it in
such a way that we don't have first
understanding human existence can relate
to beings only if it holds itself out
into the knot so what does that mean
holding itself up into the nothing find
a cliff and just sort of hang out and to
you know nothing that's well that's not
actually nothing this will talk about
why so that frames our inquiry and we're
gonna move through this pretty quickly
and I'm not going to be able to touch on
every single important point in this
because we're trying to get this done
with it you know a certain time frame I
should mention that I'm using the Crouch
translation there's other translations
available of this Heidegger is somebody
who's notoriously difficult to translate
she doesn't love playing around with
language but I think this is this is an
adequate way of
approaching it so he says what is
metaphysics the question awakens
expectations of a discussion about
metaphysics this will forego so
Heidegger is already switching the the
deck at the beginning instead we're
going to take a particular metaphysical
question why well you know because any
place that we approach metaphysics any
to where we go in we're going to be
dealing with the rest of metaphysics so
we're going to start with with this what
is what is science
he says metaphysical inquiry must be
posed as a whole from the essential
position of the existence that questions
we are questioning so human beings are
questioning here and now for ourselves
our existence what at what determinate
existence in the community of
researchers teachers and students so
what science is a good question at yes
in that case what happens to us
essentially in the grounds of our
existence when science becomes our
passion becomes the thing that's
motivating us so he starts off with some
general reflections about what we can
call scientific fields and he says the
scientific fields are quite diverse the
ways they treat their objects have been
create different fundamentally and if
you think about you know the university
not only as it is now but also as it was
in his time there's a lack of unity to
the different subjects that are studied
by the time that we get to art our time
there's a lot of attempts to try to
reintroduce some sort of integration or
core to it but quite often that's
unsuccessful and each of the disciplines
tends to have its own norms which don't
you know coincide too well and sometimes
don't even understand the norms of other
disciplines they reject them as being
not as scientific or not as rigorous as
their own and so you know there's a lot
of you might say it's almost like a
little babble going on within every
every University so he says when we look
at the sciences themselves from their
point of view no field takes precedence
over now they're neither nature over
history
or vice-versa each of them has their own
type of rigor their own type of perhaps
exactness or not and he says according
to the idea behind them in the sciences
we approach what's essential in things
so that's key it's not just having a
method it's not just being rigorous in
some sense of the term it's that there's
a pretense to actually getting at the
things as they really are
so if you're a sociologist you believe
that there actually is stuffed up there
like social facts for society or group
dynamics that you're analyzing and if
you don't well then you're you're really
not going to do much sociology where
you're going to be a complete cynic if
you're a psychology you've got to
believe that you're actually
investigating something ended with the
human mind or you're not doing
psychology after a certain point if
you're a physicist you've got to believe
that what you're doing actually has
something to do with the physical world
as we observe it if you're a historian
whatever you know school you may be made
along to whether you're Marxist or Laza
and all that story or pick whatever you
want you actually have to think there
actually is something like history out
there may be multiple histories whatever
you like but there has to be something
out there that you're actually trying to
understand so how is science different
from other things he says science is
exceptional in that in a way peculiar to
it it gives the matter itself explicitly
in soul in for the first and last word
in such impartiality of inquiry
requiring determining and grounding a
peculiarly delineated submission to
beings themselves obtains in order that
they may reveal themselves this is kind
of idealized on Heidegger's part not
everybody who's doing science actually
does this but this is part of it that
again if you want to be a sociologist
you can't just sort of make it up as you
go along or pick whatever theory you
happen to like because you know that
makes you feel good you actually have to
like observe some phenomena and see
whether the theory can actually coincide
or those phenomena well enough that
without too much fudging you could make
some sense out of it
what he calls a submission to being
themselves so in science he talks about
a special relation that's taking place
there and he talks about this this sort
of trinity he says man one being among
others pursues science in this pursuit
nothing less transpires than the
eruption by one being called man on to
the whole of beings were the
investigators were a type of being and
returning to the rest of being and we're
actually penetrating into it and making
it become something for ourselves for
our consciousness so that we can
actually come to Noah and he says this
is this eruption that breaks up it in
its way helps beings above all to
themselves so if we want to take just
physical sciences for example or or or
biology by studying the things we're
studying beings that are that are there
out in the world and by our learning
about them we are helping those beings
be more than they previously were we're
helping them unfold some of themselves
in a way there's that there's a bit of
idealism now I want to go out further
from this and not dwell on that
Heidegger says this Trinity relation to
the world attitude an interruption in
its radical unity brings a luminous
simplicity and aptness of design to
scientific existence if we are to take
explicit possession of the design
illuminated in the this way for
ourselves and here's where he makes a
critical turning we must say but he says
three things that to which the relation
to the world refers our beings
themselves and nothing besides that from
which every attitude takes its guidance
our beings themselves and nothing
besides that which the scientific
confrontation and the eruption occurs
our beings themselves and beyond that
nothing so we have you know in each of
these beings themselves and nothing else
here's where the critical turn takes
place
science looked at the beings themselves
and it doesn't look at that nothing
Heidegger is going to look at that
nothing so he says what is remarkable is
that he sees the scientific man doesn't
look at the beyond that nothing what
about this nothing is it an accident
that we talk this way so automatically
is this just a function of our language
could we have a language in which there
isn't any such thing like that or is
there something essential going on there
says what trouble do we take concerning
there's nothing the nothing is rejected
precisely by science given up as a
nullity but when we give up to nothing
in such a way do we know and concede it
there's something about the very concept
of nothing that becomes tricky and in
ways that don't apply to the beings and
tigers not the first person to grapple
with this by the way as a matter of fact
I think that there are some philosophers
who if he had actually you know looked
at them carefully he might have gone
even further with this I think st.
Anselm is one of them because st. Anselm
actually has a lot of reflections on
what nothing means now we want to move
ahead to what he calls the elaboration
of the question we have to elaborate the
question of the nothing we have to ask
what is the nothing and that seems kind
of silly at first then he says we're
going to try to ask about it what is the
nothing our first approach is something
unusual in it in our asking we're
positing that nothing as if it's
something that is we're talking about
the nothing as if it is a a being and
some ways in which people have tried to
conceptualize this this idea of nothing
have been by talking about the way the
mind carries out abstraction we abstract
away from all beings and then we negate
that so I would say something that
somebody who fits that would be you know
John Locke for example the idea is that
you think about being and then just
take that away and now you've got
nothing left right that's carried out by
the intellect and Heidegger says well
that's not really original enough for us
then the nothing is really an artifact
of human thinking it doesn't have any
real being existence even to talk about
being her existence is a little bit of a
you know misnomer here but it doesn't
doesn't have anything of its own in that
case we can go even further he talks
about universal logic and then he says
thinking which is this always
essentially thinking about something
must act in a way contrary to its own
essence when it thinks about than
nothing can we tamper he asks with the
rule of logic is not intellect the task
masks the taskmaster in this question
nothing only with its help can we define
that nothing impose it as a problem
which is true only devours itself for
the nothing is the negation of the
totality of beings that is non being
pure and simple but with that we bring
them nothing under the higher
determination of the negative so I'm hot
what's going on here you're actually
staying actually draw a little line here
one way of thinking about that noting is
that first you start with negation and
then you get to the nothing as a
particular way of negating and negating
everything so you start with everything
but negate that and then you get nothing
and this is carried out by the intellect
so yes does not do not the not negated
miss and thereby negation to represent
the higher determination under which the
nothing Falls is a particular kind of
negated manner is the nothing given only
because the not ie negation so the not
is given or is it the other way around
is our first nothing and then only after
that other things other types of
negatives well that's going to be
Heidegger's view to give it away so he
says that the nothing is more original
than the not and negation and he says if
this thesis is right then the
possibility of negation is an act of the
intellect and thereby the intellect here
somehow dependent on nothing so a
massive shift of perspective is taking
place here kunt will often talked about
his own philosophy as carrying out a
Copernican shift you know
Copernicus had you know shifted
attention from the earth to the Sun you
know instead of the Sun circling the
earth the earth actually circles the Sun
Khan talked but his philosophy is doing
that in terms of the subject the knowing
subject and the objects of the world
Heidegger is doing this in terms of
negation and beings in terms of nothing
and beings this is a very radical move
so he says how can the intellect hope to
decide on the nothing
and what this points out to us is that
maybe the intellect is not the only tool
or the only thing by which we can
encounter and conceptualize and make
sense out of the nothing he says that
nothing is given prior to all these
other things like negation that means we
must be able to experience it and he
talks about a fundamental experience of
the nothing so he says you know as
surely as we can never comprehend
absolutely the whole of beings in
themselves this is what would be
requirement if we're going to try to
have the nothing be the negation of
beings as a totality the everything and
we take that away in our minds we switch
it around and change the polarity and
then we get to nothing we would actually
have to be able to conceive of the
totality of the
in our mind he says we can't comprehend
absolutely the whole of beings in
themselves ah but we do find they're so
stationed in the midst of beings that
are revealed revealed together somehow
as a whole in the end an essential
distinction prevails between
comprehending the whole of beings and
themselves and finding oneself in the
midst of beings as a whole
the former is impossible in principle
the latter happens all the time in our
existence every time that we're acting
we can't help but be in a world this is
one of the basic ideas of Heidegger it's
what you call thoroughness for being
also being in the world
we're always surrounded by objects even
if you take us away and put us in an
isolation chamber you're still in an
isolation chamber you always have some
sort of things going on with your
interior life as well some sort of
succession there's always time you don't
choose that and that is prior to any one
single experience that you're going to
have so he says no matter how fragmented
our everyday existence may appear to be
it always deals with beings in a unity
of the whole if only in a shadowy way so
that's that's sort of a basic starting
point or an axiom for private even and
precisely when we're not actually busy
with things or ourselves this as a whole
overcomes us for example and easy to use
as an example here we're gonna look at a
few different examples in genuine
boredom boredom is what boredom is
something that we call a mood and the
nothing is actually going to be revealed
to us through mood or if you like
feeling or F activity attunement is
another way of translating this the
affective side of us so boredom what's
going on when we're when we're bored he
says boredom is still distance when it's
only this book or that play in that
business or this idleness that drags on
interrupts when one is bored
when that characterizes one's whole
experience of the world profound boredom
drifting here and there in the abysus of
our existence like a muffling fog very
nice phenomenological description
removes all things and human beings and
one's self along them into a remarkable
and difference it's very difficult to
describe moods and Heidegger is fairly
good at that some other people who by
the way are very good at that
in the phenomenological movement that
Heidegger is part of would be mock
Schaller Dedra found Hildebrand
there was a Marilyn Ponte maurice
merleau-ponty is also very good at that
start to a certain extent is also quite
good at that too so what's another
possibility he says another possibility
of such revelation is concealed that our
joy in the presence of the design and
that's simply the person of a human
being whom we love so he's talking about
two different effective modalities there
the love that we bear to it towards the
other human being and he says not just
the person but there does end so you
mean something deeper right their very
existence their very being there this
mining also you know we might not
necessarily be romantic long it could be
could be care it could be friendship and
what does it produce it produces a kind
of joy and joy is an affective attea joy
as a mood joy reveals to us a different
world surrounding us in a different
world within us than does boredom or you
know before we go on to talk about some
of the other moons that he's going to
talk about likewise humiliation you know
if that is your fundamental way in which
you're experiencing the worldly
effectively that's a very different
world as well
depression sadness another fundamental
way of experience
constant frustration anger another
effective modality and we could go
through through a lot of these one of
the things that he says is he says such
being attuned in which we are in one way
or another which we have a mood and
which determines us through and through
lets us find ourselves among beings as a
whole this is quite radical again
Heidegger is not the only person to to
be saying stuff like this he's part of a
a whole movement of people who are
paying attention to the effective life
of the human being and how it actually
pervades our intellectual 'ti our
volition our action that activity is not
somehow just you know lower or posterior
to what's going on with us that it
fundamentally pervades human being and
our existence in the world dietrich von
Hildebrand again and Schaller are
fitting in with that other
phenomenologist starts again to a
certain degree in who he is coming after
Heidegger and Gabriela Marcel will be
saying this a lot of other people are
saying this PETA time but Heidegger is
going to focus in on one thing in
particular so let's look at that he says
such being attuned in which we are one
way or another and which determines us
through and through lets us find
ourselves among gangs as a whole so mood
F activity is kind of a glue it's not
just a filter through which we see the
world it's kind of a glue that holds
together the particular configurations
that gives things the meanings by which
they cohere with each other so again the
angry person who's characteristically
angry is seeing objects the same objects
in different configurations but with
different intentionality
than the person who feels joy and the
person who characters are
characteristically feels gratitude than
the person who characteristically feels
sadness or boredom
so he says that this founding mode of
attunement not only reveals being as a
whole in various ways but this revealing
far from being incidental is also the
basic occurrence of our dot sign our
being there it's part of how we are into
the world we feel our way into the world
you could say now he says if we do not
let ourselves be misled by the formal
impossibility of the question of the
nothing if we ask this question in spite
of this we have to ask we have to ask
how how this is going to fit in with
mood what kind of moods can reveal up to
us than nothing
he says what we call a feeling is
neither a transitory epiphenomenon nor
simply an impulse but when moods of this
sort bring us face to face with beings
as a whole they conceal from us the
nothing that we're seeking so it's their
very ability to reveal to us the world
and different faces of objects that we
might not have seen otherwise that
prevents us from being in the sea but
nothing besides the beings the end moves
now he says we come to share even less
in the opinion that the negation of
beings as a whole that are revealed to
us in mood places us before the nothing
such a thing could only happen in a
correspondingly original mood which is
the most proper sense of unveiling
reveals that nothing well is there one
mood among all the others one
effectivity one feeling we could say
that could reveal to us than nothing
Heidegger thinks that there is and only
one so what is that he says this Canon
does occur although rarely enough and
only for a moment in the fundamental
mode of ings
so this is a central high daguerreian
concept you're gonna see it you know
worked out and a great length and being
in time and in some some other works as
well that anxiety is really the most
important of all the moods why because
it reveals to us something that the
other moods cannot so it's showing us
the primordial is he says primordial
significance or structure design or
human being
the anxiety says is fundamentally
different from fear how is it different
than fear we become afraid in the face
of this or that particular being that
threatens us in this or that particular
respect so fear is always focused on
some sort of threatening object some
sort of danger fear in the face of
something is also in each case fear for
something in particular because fewer
possesses this trait of being fear in
the face of it fear for he who fears and
it is afraid is captive to the mood in
which he finds himself striving to
rescue himself from this particular
thing he becomes unsure of everything
else and consequently loses his head so
if your is a sort of decentering effect
but it also focuses you on something
anxiety says does not let such confusion
arise much to the contrary a peculiar
call pervasive anxiety is indeed anxiety
in the face of but not in the face of
this or that thing you can think of it
as an empty form if you want to be very
conscious about this anxiety in the face
of is always anxiety for but not for
this or that the indeterminate Nastase
of which and for which we become anxious
as no mere lack of determination
so this is where you reject the notion
of an empty content form but rather the
essential impossibility of determining
it
that's what's characteristic about
anxiety it can't fix upon an object
that's what makes it anxiety he says in
anxiety
one feels ill at ease or literally not
at home I namely what is it that makes
one feel ill at ease this is we cannot
say what it is before which one feels
ill at ease as a whole that is so for
one all things and we ourselves sink
into indifference is how he describes it
this however not in the sense of mere
disappearance rather in this very
receding things turn toward us and
unsettle us the receiving of beings as a
whole that closes in on us in anxiety
oppresses us we can get into a whole lot
of things so he's using terminology very
spatial terminology for things like
receding at the same time and yet
filling you know filling in the gaps
between us now he says anxiety what does
it reveal but nothing we hover it
anxiety more precisely anxiety leaves us
hanging because it induces the slipping
away of beings as a whole this implies
that we ourselves we humans who are in
being in the midst of being slip away
from ourselves
so when anxiety is going on it's not
just other beings outside of ourselves
that we're kind of losing a hold on that
are moving around and changing their
their metaphorical position relative to
us it's our own self that's a really
profound idea there he goes on and he
says because beings as a whole slip away
so that the nothing crowds around in the
face of all of the anxiety all utterance
of the is being is to talk about the
gifts fall silent we find ourselves not
able to say anything so what is the
nothing then that we're being placed
into encounter
we are an anxiety this is where we move
on to the next section the response to
the question so he says that nothing
reveals itself in anxiety but it doesn't
reveal itself as a being just as little
as it given as an object anxiety is not
the kind of grasping of the nothing at
me and say okay here's what I'm afraid
of here's what's bothering me all the
same that nothing reveals itself in and
through anxiety he says so it's an
encounter now what kind of encounter is
is we have to give a description of some
sort and so Heidegger's attempting to do
that and he says it anxiety beings as a
whole become superfluous in what sense
does this happen beings are not
annihilated by anxiety so that nothing
is left how could they be when anxiety
finds itself in utter impotence with
beings as a whole rather than nothing
makes itself known with beings and in
beings expressively as a kind of
slipping away the whole so it's not
anihilation of beings it's not
destroying them it's not facing them
it's not erasing them it's not negating
them either by virtue of the the
activity of the intellect he says it's
neither of those that nothing rises to
meet us already before either of those
and I'm actually going to skip ahead a
little bit to bring up something else
that comes up in respect to this he says
the not once again to go back to this
that not does not originate through
negation rather negation is grounded in
the knot that Springs from what he calls
the kneel ation of the nothing the way
in which the nothing manifests itself
kneel Asian Neagle is Latin for nothing
right so the nothing nothing is is how
Heidegger is expressing it's the
activity of the nothing then nothing you
know if we want to play around with
words negation is only one way of
mediating it's only one modality of that
so negation annihilation these are two
negative thing
but they're not than nothing itself
there they're after than nothing
they're not prior to it they're not what
gives them nothing it's activity instead
what it was they say it anxiety there's
a kind of bewildered calm the nothing
itself does not attract it is
essentially repelling but this repulsion
is itself as such a parting gesture
towards beings that are submerging as a
whole this wholly repelling gesture
towards beings that are in retreat as a
whole which is the action of the nothing
that oppresses design and anxiety
because the essence of the nothing kneel
ation no that is not that that's a lot
of words that's easy to say that's easy
to read what the hell does all that mean
and that's one of the key points I think
to to go over so let's let's look at
that wedding
once again this holy repelling gesture
towards beings that are in retreat as a
whole which is the action of the nothing
that oppresses designed in anxiety is
the essence of the nothing dilation so
let's work our way backwards put aside
the word annihilation for a moment the
essence of the nothing he's looking at
what makes the nothing nothing what does
he add it's very core so it's the action
of the nothing impressing design innings
in anxiety it's what's going on in the
experience of anxiety which is not the
experience of a thing but of the nothing
that pervades all these other things and
allows them to be in some one way or
another
Heidegger's because they meet elated but
if we want to get rid of that technical
term let's say negative modalities to be
used towards that we'll look at some of
these negative modalities in just a few
minutes so he says kneel ation is not
some fortuitous incident rather it
discloses these beings and they're full
but heretofore concealed strangeness as
what is radically off other with respect
to the nothing now this is a really
important point so we need to do a
little bit of research here
if we want to be really funny about it
we can say it's not to Rhydian erasure
on high daguerreian erasure so we have
beings and we have in the world
and we also have design itself as a
special kind of being and these all
exist because they have their beings
right and they are related to each other
and now we're gonna use spatial imagery
understanding that this can't possibly
be adequate to it though we don't have
to represent it in some way in order to
wrap our heads around so
we should understand this in a sort of
way like where the nothing actually like
has all sorts of groups and and
capillaries into the beings themselves
so it's not something just totally
outside of beings but it is something
that pervades being at every single
moment every space every interstice of
the beings that are so the nothing
allows the beings to actually stand out
as what they are in relation to each
other but also for design we're going to
look at exactly how that occurs in some
some very important ways in just a few
minutes but this is a very original
thing that he's talking about at first
he talks about this only on the ground
of the original revelation of the
nothing can human existence approach and
penetrate beings can there be a
back-and-forth between human being and
beings it's the very fact that we're
able to engage in these different
needing behaviors which include negation
but are not comprised solely with
indication so there's nothing neil aids
and we Neely - we make things have the
activity we have view them with nothing
and the elation can include creation
destruction right but it's going to
include other things too
so he says design means being held out
into the nothing design is and I didn't
represent it quite as well
shouldn't like half way one way or the
other
Don's idea is not only in the world of
beings the plenitude of beings it's also
held out into the nothing this is the
condition of our freedom this is the
condition of our knowledge this is our
condition of our relations as designed
with the other kinds of beings like he
says without the original revelation of
the nothing no selfhood and no freedom
this is also what allows us to have
transcendence we transcend beings
nothing also transcends beings
also when we experience transcendence
we're always going to be tempted to turn
that transcendence into a kind of being
or configuration of beings and as soon
as we do that it loses its character of
transcendence which means to be held out
into the nothing and it becomes
something so there's there's a kind of
dynamic interplay there that goes on in
any case let's go back to this design
means being held out into the nothing
holding itself out into the nothing
design is in every case already beyond
beings as a whole in the way that we
exist as human beings we are already
something that exceeds the universe the
phenomenal world even our own interior
world as we know it how is that possible
by virtue of the nothing so he says with
that the answer to the question of the
nothing is gained so this is a very key
point the nothing is neither an object
nor any being at all then nothing comes
forward neither for itself nor next to
beings to which it would as it would
adhere for human existence that nothing
makes possible the openness of beings as
such it makes it possible for us to
permeate beings to penetrate them in
knowledge in
action in even our effectivity our care
for them our interest in them that
nothing does not merely serve as the
counter concept of beings it's not
something that the intellect by itself
derives rather it originally belongs to
their essential unfolding as such in the
being capital being of beings the
Malaysian of the nothing occurs once
again one of those hiding gear in you
know you read it you're like whoa what
ever was that that was said in the being
of beings in what makes beings what they
are capital B of small B beings the me
elation of the nothing occurs the
activity of the nothing the curse so
what is that well he doesn't actually
tell us all the possible modalities of
me elation he's going to tell us a few
of these as examples he says going out a
little bit further negation cannot claim
to be the solar leading the illative
behavior in which da sign remains shaken
by the dilation of the nothing onion
lake and handsome so
the antagonism is a type of Neela to the
behavior stinging rebuke because they
rebuked by what about what but we're
gonna move past that he says they have a
more abysmal source than the measured
negation of thought galling failure
merciless prohibition
finally is to my favorite negative
because I'm you know I met a physician
at heart privation
bitter privation is more burdensome he
says these possibilities of needle tube
behavior forces in which design bears
it's throwing us without mastering and
thrown this is like being put into the
world that you know without being able
to to control that are not mere types of
negation they are not reducible to just
saying not to something they are in some
ways not as primordial as the nothing
itself or annihilation itself but they
are just as deep they are just as
primordial as the intellect saying not
to something antagonism is just as real
just as metaphysical as destroying
something or saying no to it reviewed
and you can think here not just a rebuke
as heidegger's talking about it think of
the entire social world
I mean Aristotle and Heidegger is a big
fan of aerosol conceives of one of the
central dimensions of our moral
existence one of the ways in which we
actually get cues about things is
through praise and blame rebuke is
another type of blame criticism failure
the experience of failure is not merely
something not happening
there is something determinative about
it that goes beyond that prohibition
likewise prohibition is not reducible
just to annihilation or negation or even
antagonism there's something
determinative specific about that
finally privation and the ancients near
this very well so you know Aristotle did
Augustine understood this you know he
was the privation of the good st. Anselm
works that out even further Thomas
Aquinas I'm not really sure if he
actually advances beyond the and saw I'm
not convinced to that myself but a lot
of Thomas say that he did so I will just
say that that he did the understanding
of privation as something very different
than a mere lack of being or being taken
away or a negation of something
predation is a lack of something that
want to be there these are all types of
needle at the behavior these are all
things that design not only has
inflicted on it the design itself does
both with itself and with other designs
and with beings and with the world the
totality of beings as a whole he calls
us the saturation of existence by
militant behavior and he says that in
this anxiety is there it's only sleeping
its breath Quivers perpetually through
design only slightly and those who are
jittery imperceptibly in the oh yes oh
no no men of affairs but most readily in
the reserved and most assuredly and
those who are basically daring the
anxiety of those who are daring cannot
be opposed to joy or even to the
comfortable enjoyment of tranquilized
muscle it stands in secret alliance with
the cheerfulness and gentleness of
creative longing original anxiety the
kind of anxiety that reveals to us our
meta physical condition and that of all
existence as a whole can awaken an
existence at any moment it needs no
unusual event to rouse it although it
all it often helps to have some unusual
event doesn't it like the death of a
loved one or the loss of a job or you
know usually it happens through one of
these sorts of things some annihilated
some neil ative
event that takes place but it doesn't
have to happen that way they could just
happen because it comes out of the
balloon and Heidegger thinks that we
actually spend a lot of our energy
trying to avoid this realization trying
to avoid anxiety now what is the upshot
of this for metaphysics it says this is
gonna bring us face to face with
metaphysics itself remember all of us
they answer the question what is madness
metaphysics is inquiry beyond or over
beings
well what turned out to be beyond or
over beings right design which is not
just confined to the realm of beings
even though it is a being and the
nothing
so metaphysics is fundamentally it's not
it is about beings but it's
fundamentally about these nothing and
design so he says to what extent does
the question concerning the nothing
permeate and embrace the whole of
metaphysics well here we have to look at
things a bit historically it says for a
long time metaphysics has expressed the
nothing in a proposition clearly
susceptible of more than one meaning and
this is coming from classical
metaphysics ex nihilo Neil fit from
nothing nothing comes to be and the idea
is you can't get something out of
nothing so there can't really be any
nothing to begin with you got to start
with something but then something comes
along in the world of thought and
changes that and that is the
judeo-christian thought the concept of a
God who creates X kneadable I would have
nothing and this is why there has to be
a philosophical or theological analysis
of what it means for there to be nothing
or for nothing to be or nothing to be
nothing you know ex nihilo fit ends
grant from nothing comes created being
from the nothing come becomes now the
nothing he says becomes the counter
concept of being proper the
ends god the ends in clay optim the
uncreated being here to the
interpretation of that nothing
designates the basic consumption of
beings but the metaphysical discussion
of being stays on the same level as the
question of the nothing so if you're not
understanding the nothing and Heidegger
thinks that Christians are fundamentally
misunderstood the nature of the death as
a matter of fact he thinks that a lot of
other ways of understanding it you know
misunderstood it as well and he talks
about Hegel here as well and he says
this cursory historical review shows
that nothing as the counter concept of
being proper that is as its negation not
as nothing but if the nothing becomes
any problem at all then this opposition
does not merely undergo a somewhat more
significant determination it awakens for
the first time Heidegger thinks that
something fundamentally new is coming
about through not necessarily as
analysis but through where we are in
modernity and the way in which design
can understand itself in in modernity
and also misunderstand so the first time
it's possible the proper formulation of
the metaphysical question concerning the
being capital B of beings the nothing
does not remain the indeterminate
opposite of beings but reveals itself is
belonging to the being of beings it's
what allows beings to actually have
their their being this is what he talks
about Hegel this is pure enough that be
pure being and enough that pure nothing
are the same this is an angles logic and
he says well that's right being and the
nothing do belong together not because
both from the point of view of the
Galleon concept of thought agree and
they're indeterminate us and immediacy
but rather because being capital P is
itself essentially finite not integer
fine it reveals itself only in the
transcendence of the design Don's head
is the only being for which other beings
actually are as such then the design is
held out into the nothing
so he says assuming that the question of
being is such is the encompassing
question of metaphysics the one question
that puts everything else into proper
perspective then the question of the
nothing proves to be such that it
embraces the whole of metaphysics so
interestingly think about where we've
come from by playing with this this word
and then digging at it and thinking
about it and you know actually looking
at an experience of it getting more and
more understanding of it and realizing
that our experiences our experiences of
it we've come to realize one of the
fundamental questions of metaphysics not
just what is being what is nothing and
he says the old proposition thanks Neil
Oni hilf it is therefore found to
contain another sense one appropriate to
the problem of being itself that runs ex
nihilo ohmnha ends quite ends fit from
the nothing and that the translation
here and from the nothing all beings as
beings come to be I would actually say
every being the as a being comes to be
only in the nothing of design to beings
as a whole in you know a quarter there
most proper possibility that is in a
finite way determined come to themselves
so he goes on and he talks about now
we're gonna get back to science
scientific existence what makes science
actually possible remember we go back to
this idea of science penetrates beings
it tries to get to the very bottom of
what makes beings beings tries to
understand them well what made that
possible something that science couldn't
itself conceptualize or even realize the
importance and the centrality of because
science doesn't do metaphysics actually
except for versus the science of
metaphysics science misunderstands the
very condition for its possibility this
is what we call doing a transcendental
critique looking at the conditions for
the possibility of something science is
unable to properly understand one of the
very conditions for its possibility as a
human activity has something carried out
by design on two beings that's really
important inside that he is so he says
only if science exists on the basis of
metaphysics can it actually advance
further in its essential task which is
not to amass and classify bits of
knowledge but to disclose an ever
renewed fashion the entire region of
truth in nature and history so only if
the science is actually engage in some
sort of dialogue with Heidegger haiduk
area and metaphysics which he thinks of
course is not hiding area metaphysics
but metaphysics as it must be will it be
possible for science to do what it was
supposed to do or what its possibility
was and he says only because the nothing
is manifest on the ground of design can
the total strangeness of beings
overwhelm us only when the total
strangeness of beings oppresses us does
it arouse and evoke wonder only on the
ground of wonder the revelation of the
nothing does the why the central
question not just for the scientists but
even more for the philosopher not just
what is in front of us why is it the way
it is and we can ask even further why is
there anything rather than just plain
old nothing these are fundamental deep
questions that Heidegger thinks and
anybody who's really engaged in learning
what being is we're learning what
particular beings are ought to be asking
and unfortunately they're not most of
the time he says human beings can relate
to being
two beings only if it holds itself out
into the nothing going beyond beings
occurs in the essence of design but this
going beyond this is doing metaphysics
this is metaphysics itself that's the
quote that I I have is the third quote
that we began with this implies that
metaphysics belongs to the very nature
of human being it's neither a division
of academic philosophy in which case you
can sort of put it off in the corner nor
is it a field of arbitrary notions and
by the way for many people doing it as
academic philosophy I think the other
philosophers actually conceived of it as
a field of arbitrary notions metaphysics
is not in particularly high repute these
days and among many with whom it is in
high repute it tends to be a very
technical subject that is totally out of
touch with the classic history of
metaphysics and confined itself to very
very small realms of inquiry which is
the total opposite of how a metaphysics
is understood by somebody like Heidegger
metaphysics he says is the basic
occurrence of design so we're all doing
metaphysics either poorly or well or
somewhere in between by virtue of this
very structure of nothing design and
beings we're always doing metaphysics
insofar as were coming to know anything
to care about anything to love anything
to hate anything to work on something to
to grow to do anything to think anything
to say anything we're already engaged in
some sort of activity that involves us
with metaphysics because all of us are
in fact
all of us whether we experience anxiety
or not we are all engaged with the
nothing it's unavoidable but it's also
unsuspected it's not looked at by most
of us and we have many ways of
anesthetize in ourselves against the
pushing it away of making sure that
these questions will never arise to busy
ourselves is one technique to focus so
much just on one particular thing to get
ourselves caught in dynamics that
replicate themselves endlessly these are
all ways to keep ourselves from actually
experience
experiencing the kind of calm and
stillness and all these things that you
know with beings receding and coming and
pressing us that's involved in this
fundamental mood of anxiety so he says
well you know what are they what are the
implications here is the question of the
nothing unfolded here is they actually
questioned us the nothing is not
something in nerves it questions us then
we have not simply brought metaphysics
before us in an extrinsic manner nor we
merely been transposed to it we can't be
transposed there at all because insofar
as we exist we're already there we're
again we're already engaged in
metaphysics by the very kind of being
which we have in which we are so so long
as man exists philosophizing of some
sort occurs philosophy what we call
philosophy is metaphysics getting
underway in which philosophy comes to
itself into its explicit tasks so
Heidegger has a very interesting
conception not only a philosophy but of
all human intellectual activity that
involves us in having to engage in
metaphysics and we're going to do that a
lot better in his view if we actually
ask and try to probe into this question
what is metaphysics he provides us with
an answer here but it's an answer that
requires a
continual questioning it's not a closing
of the book and providing you with some
datas of information which then you
write down on the test this would have
to be incorporated into one's own life
as part of the life not only of the mind
but of activity of activity and of
action